merci ma chère collègue dans la suite
discussions général la parole était
monsieur pierre charon pour cinq minutes
de la parole mon cher collègue monsieur
le président madame le garde des sceaux
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission mais chers
collègues nous abordons aujourd'hui
l'examen d'un projet de loi qui aurait
pu être l'occasion de réfléchir à une
politique pénale plus ambitieuses pour
répondre aux besoins et aux enjeux d'une
justice pour tous est comprise par tous
annoncée puis reportée municipal à haut
risque oblige attendu contesté même au
sein du gouvernement comme en témoignent
les missives du ministre de l'intérieur
en juillet 2013 au président de la
république
il alertait sur un projet qui reposait
selon ses termes sur un socle de
légitimité fragile la conférence du
consensus et sur le fait que les
conclusions du jury avait été l'objet de
fortes réserves au sein même de la
magistrature décidément l'antisarkozysme
demeure le principal moteur de la
majorité comme en atteste comme en
attestent les dangereuses amendement
adopté en commission des lois de notre
assemblée dont la suppression des
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs
récidivistes ou celui de la rétention de
sûreté situation aggravante une réforme
de cette nature n'aurait jamais dû être
examiné en procédure accélérée au
préjudice des droits du parlement et
d'un débat serein et constructif pour
l'avenir de notre société
premier constat les français expriment
leur volonté très nette de protection et
de fermeté
72 % demandent une plus grande sévérité
à l'égard des récidivistes et une
limitation des remises en liberté
et bien force est de constater qu'avec
ce texte ils n'auront pas de quoi être
rassuré puisque vous faites exactement
l'inversé de ce qu'attendent les
français
vous avez la conviction erronée que l'on
a car certes rohan francs
en ce que la prison serait l'école du
crime est cassée motif il faut prendre
des dispositions pour empêcher le
recours à l'emprisonnement à tout prix
personne n'est opposé au fait de ne pas
enfermer en prison des personnes qui
n'ont rien à y faire
mais il ya aussi des personnes qui
devraient y être et qui n'y sont pas
outils ne sont pas condamnés par
ailleurs l'idée que c'est la prison qui
crée la récidive est fausse et
caricatural c'est bien la récidive qui
conduit en prison
et comme souligné isabelle gorce la
directrice de l'administration
pénitentiaire que vous avez nommé madame
le ministre
les courtes peines pose des problèmes
complexes beaucoup en maison d'arrêt ont
déjà été condamnés à des peines en
milieu ouvert et c'est donc à la suite
d'échecs successifs qu'il finisse près
de condamner une petite peine
d'emprisonnement ferme et légumes elle
il vaudrait donc sûrs et former et
encadrer les alternatives à la détention
vous multipliez les erreurs d'analysé
les statistiques pénales du conseil de
l'europe publié récemment le démontre en
réalité la vraie question que vous
escamoté de manière purement idéologique
c'est celle du dimensionnement du parc
immobilier pénitentiaire vous préféré
vider les prisons pour faire de la place
plutôt que de revoir le dimensionnement
structurelles de notre parc et d'y
mettre les crédits nécessaires
notre pays a besoin de 100 mille places
de prison il n'en compte que 50 7500
vous avez abandonné le projet de
l'ancienne majorité qui prévoyait la
construction nécessaires et timide de 24
mille places de prison indispensable
pour nous mettre en conformité avec les
normes européennes et pour faire
exécuter effectivement les peines
d'emprisonnement pour les deux années à
venir
deux mille places seulement sont
budgétés en réalité ce texte est une
succession disposition inquiétante
tout d'abord la suppression des peines
plancher pour les délinquants d'hérésie
des listes c'est une posture idéologique
qui envoie un message de laxisme à
l'égard des récidivistes
ensuite la création la contrainte pénale
cette nouvelle peine qui est en fait une
liberté encadrée qui permettra d'éviter
un peu plus encore l'incarcération
la dernière version des plus extrémistes
de la commission des lois est une peine
autonome que les juges devront plus
l'opportunité d'appliquer et qui se
substituera purement et simplement à la
prison en cas de vol recel de vol
filouteries dégradations usage de
stupéfiants délit de fuite et de
certains délits routiers
vous souhaitiez donner de la place à
l'aménagement de peine mais madame la
ministre vous ne semblez plus maîtriser
la voix vous avez ouverte tant les plus
jusqu'au boutiste vous donne du fil à
retordre mais il y a aussi demandé
l'avis de monsieur valls vous verrez
mais il ya aussi dans la panoplie la
création d'une peine d'ajournement aux
fins d'investigations sur la
personnalité ou la situation l'intéressé
dont la principale conséquence sera
l'augmentation du nombre des peines
inexécutées il est aussi la procédure
d'examen automatique de tous les
dossiers des détenus pour les libérer
aux deux tiers de leur peine et sept en
réalité à la moitié du fait des crédits
de réduction de peine qui sont autant de
signaux dangereux ne vaudrait-il pas
mieux s'attaquer aux délais d'exécution
des décisions de justice
plus d'un tiers des peines de prison
ferme ne sont pas exécutés plus de sept
mois après leur prononcé et 25 % ne le
sont qu'à près un an
la peine est dissuasive mais pour cela
il faut qu'elle soit effective il faut
assortir votre réforme de moyens à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
bannir toute disposition faisant
prospérer l'impunité assurer la sécurité
des personnes et des biens de notre pays
sans quoi nous ne pouvons voter ce texte
je vous remercie à ces mots chat
collègues